We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P here
is a question that I'm gonna assume is being
asked in good faith, but it hasn't been answered
so many times.
Take a listen.
My name is Louis G. would you kindly address
the tax increase?
That would probably happen if Sanders or Warren
instituted their Medicare for all bill probably
worded that incorrectly, but you know what
I mean.
Yeah.
Listen, so Elizabeth Warren doesn't have a
Medicare for all bill.
She said she likes Bernie's, but she's open
to other ideas.
We don't know exactly how her plan would be
funded.
Although she has said total costs would go
down, the rich and corporations would pay
more.
Okay, let's focus on Bernie's.
Bernie has addressed the costs and I've addressed
the costs.
Your total costs would go down under Medicare
for all.
There would be a payroll tax that is added.
It would be a couple percentage points to
the average worker.
Corporations would pay a piece of it as well.
Premiums go away, copays go away, co-insurance
goes away.
All of these costs go down and then you pay
a little bit through your payroll tax.
If you can't afford it, if you don't have
a job, that's okay.
The numbers account for that already this
has been addressed.
There is a fair criticism that Bernie is not
always the most, uh, solid in terms of his
messaging of how this will work.
It's been addressed.
The proposal to pay for it is out there, and
I'm not criticizing the collar, but lots of
people just haven't seen that to continue
to pretend as some are doing, that the cost
element hasn't been addressed or that the
tax element hasn't been dealt with.
It has now.
You might not like it.
You might disagree with the approach.
You could disagree that the numbers have been
calculated correctly.
Reasonable people can disagree about whether
the cost of the program has been properly
assessed.
That's all very reasonable.
But to pretend that Bernie hasn't addressed
this time and time again, he has and, uh,
it's widely available online and I encourage
you to check it out.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member@joinedpacman.com or a patron at patrion.com/david
[inaudible], the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].